[Applause]
good morning
over the course of my career i have seen
gun violence up close i've looked at
autopsy photographs
i've seen with my own two eyes what a
bullet can do
to the human body i have held hands
with the hands of parents who have lost
a child
i have seen children who were
traumatized
by the loss of a parent or sibling
and i have fought my entire career to
end this violence
and to pass reasonable gun safety laws
time and again as progress has stalled
we've all asked what are we waiting for
because we aren't waiting for a tragedy
i know that
we've had more tragedy than we can bear
we aren't waiting for solutions either
because the solutions
exist they already exist
people on both sides of the aisle
want action real people
on both sides of the aisle one action
so all that is left is the will
and the courage to act
and president joe biden has the will
and the courage to act
[Applause]
as a united states senator joe biden
took on the gun lobby not once but twice
and he won in 1993
he worked to pass the brady handgun
violation prevention act this law
established a background check system
and has
kept more than three million firearms
out of the hands of dangerous people
a year later he worked to pass another
law
to ban assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
for 10 years and as vice president
joe biden led the obama biden
administration's efforts
to reduce gun violence in fact we were
just reminiscing that he and i talked
back then
about his work because i was attorney
general at the time of california
and his work resulted in nearly
two dozen actions from narrowing the gun
show loophole
to expanding funding for mental health
services
and as you will hear in a moment
president joe biden
is a leader with great will
great determination and even greater
empathy he has seen the grief
of all of those who have lost a loved
one to gun violence
it is for them for all of us
that he will never ever give
up on this fight and it is now my great
honor
to introduce the president of the united
states joe biden
[Applause]
thank you conola madden vice president
thank you very much
you know we're joined today by the
attorney general
merrick garland who have asked to
prioritize
gun violence it's also good to see the
second gentleman
who is here and it's good to see the
first lady dr jill biden
who cares deeply about this issue as
well
and i look out there and i see so many
members of congress who've led in this
fight
so many of you who've never given up so
many of you are
absolutely determined as murphen and
others are to get this
done we've got a long way to go which
seems like we always have a long way to
go
but also today we're taking steps to
confront not just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake from what we're talking about
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution
is absolute you can't yell crowd you
can't yell fire in a crowd of movie
theater
call of freedom of speech from the very
beginning you couldn't own any weapon
you wanted to own
from the very beginning the second
amendment existed certain people weren't
allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things we're
recommending
are contrary to the constitution gun
violence
in this country is an epidemic let me
say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic and it's an international
embarrassment
you know we saw it again last night as i
was
coming to the oval office i got the word
that
in south carolina a uh a physician
uh with his wife two grandchildren
and a person working at his house was
gunned down all five so many people
so many people sitting here today know
that
well unfortunately you know
they know what it's like when the
seconds
change your life forever i've had the
pleasure of getting to meet in awful
circumstances
many of you many of you who've lost
your children your husbands your wives
you know they know what it's like to
bury a piece of their soul deep in the
earth
we understand that mark and uh
and jackie i want to tell you
it's always good to see you but not
under these circumstances
i want to say before i introduce the
rest of the folks
is you know what a lot of people have
not been through
what they've been through don't
understand it takes a lot of courage
to come to an event like this they're
absolutely
absolutely determined to make change
but mark and jackie whose son daniel was
a first grader in sandy hook elementary
school or
daniel loves sports loves outdoor sports
getting money i see my friend fred
gutenberg
his daughter jamie was a freshman at
marjory stoneman douglas high school she
was an accomplished dancer
i see brandon wolfe over the shooting at
the
at the at the impulse at the pulse club
not nightclub
he survived but his two best friends
died greg jackson who was
just walking down the street when he was
caught in crossfire of a gunfight
and of course i see a close friend of
jill's and mine
congresswoman gabby gifford who is here
who was who was speaking with her
constituents in front of a grocery store
in her state
when she was shot and a member of her
staff was killed
you know they're here
and their pain is immense and you know
what a lot of you hopefully many of you
don't know
is you've gone through a trauma no
matter how much you work to make sure
others don't go through it
every time you show up an event like
this it brings back
when you got that phone call it brings
back the immediacy
of what happened at that moment so i
genuinely mean it
thank you thank you for having the
courage
the courage to be here the courage to
continue this fight
senator blumenthal understands it a lot
of the folks out here understand it
but it takes real courage so thank you
to turn pain into purpose and demand
that we take the action that gives
meaning
to the word enough enough
enough enough because what they want you
to know
what they want you to do is not just
listen
every day in this country 316 people are
shot
every single day 106 of them
die every day
our flag was still flying at half-staff
for the victims of the horrific murder
of eight
primarily asian-american people in
georgia
when ten more lives were taken in a mass
murder
in colorado you probably didn't hear it
but between those two incidents
less than one week apart there were more
than 850 additional shootings
850 that took the lives of more than
250 people and
left 500 500 injured
this is an epidemic for god's sake and
it has to stop
so i'm here to talk about two things
first
the steps we're going to take
immediately and second
the action that needs to be taken going
forward to curb the epidemic of gun
violence
i asked the attorney general and his
team
to identify for me immediate concrete
actions i could take now
without having to go through the
congress and today i'm announcing
several initial steps my administration
is taking
to curb this epidemic of gun violence
much more need be done
but the first first want to rein in the
proliferation of so-called
ghost guns these are guns
that are homemade built from a kit that
include directions on how to finish the
firearm you can go buy the kit
they have no serial numbers so when they
show up at a crime scene they can't be
traced
and the buyers aren't required to pass a
background check to buy the kit
to make the gun consequently anyone
anyone from a criminal to a terrorist
can buy this kit as little as 30 minutes
put together
a weapon you know i want to see these
kits
treated as firearms under the gun
control act
which is going to require that the
seller and manufacturers
make the key parts with serial numbers
and run background checks on the buyers
when they walk in to buy
that package the section action
the second action we're going to take
back in 2000 year 2000 the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms released a
report on
its investigations of firearms
trafficking in america
the report was a pivotal value it was an
important tool
for policymakers when i was in the
senate and beyond at all levels
to stop firearms from being illegally
diverted into dangerous hands
today with online sales and
ghost guns times and trafficking methods
have changed
and we have to adjust we also have to
ask the justice department to release a
new
annual report this report will better
help policymakers address
firearms trafficking as it is today
not what it was yesterday a third change
we want to treat pistols modified with
stabilizing braces
with the seriousness they deserve a
stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a hell of a lot more
accurate and a mini rifle
as a result it's more lethal effectively
turning into a short-barreled rifle
that's what the alleged shooter in
boulder appears to have done
i want to be clear that these
modifications to firearms that make them
more lethal
should be subject to the national
firearms act
the national firearms act requires that
a potential owner pay
200 fee and submit their name and other
identify information to the justice
department
just as they would if they went out and
purchased a silencer
for a gun fourthly
during my campaign for president i
wanted to make it easier for states to
adopt
extreme risk protection order laws
they're also called
red flag laws which everybody in this
law
knows but many people listening do not
know
these laws allow a police or family
member
to petition a court in their
jurisdiction
and say i want you to temporarily move
from the following people
any firearm they may possess because
they're a danger and a crisis they're
presenting the danger to themselves
and to others and the court makes a
ruling
to put this in perspective more than
half of all suicides for example
involve the use of a firearm but when a
gun is not available
an attempt at suicide the death rate
drops precipitously
states that have red flag laws have seen
and see the reduction in the number of
suicides in their states
every single month by the way an average
of 53 women are shot and killed by an
intimate partner
i wrote the violence against women act
it's been a constant struggle to keep it
moving
we know red flag laws can have
significant effect in protecting women
from domestic violence
and we know red flag laws can stop mass
shooters
before they can act out their violent
plans
i'm proud excuse the point of personal
privilege we used to say in the senate
i'm proud that the red flag law in my
home state of delaware was named after
my son attorney general beau biden our
son excuse me jill
who proposed that legislation back in
2013.
i want to see a national red flag law
and legislation to incentivize states to
enact their own
red flag laws today i ask the justice
department to publish
a model red flag legislation so states
can start crafting their own laws right
now just like with background checks the
vast majority of
americans support these extreme risk
protection order laws
and it's time to put these laws on the
books and protect even more people
the attorney general will have more to
say about this in a moment
additionally we recognize that cities
across the country are experiencing
historic spikes
and homicides as the law enforcement can
tell you
the violence is hitting black and brown
communities the hardest
homicide is the leading cause of death
of black
boys and men ages 15 to 34
the leading cause of death
but there are proven strategies that
reduce gun violence in urban communities
and there are programs that have
demonstrated they can reduce homicides
up to 60 percent in urban communities
but many of these have been badly
underfunded or not funded at all of late
gun violence in america for those you
think of this from an economic
standpoint listening to me
estimated to cost the nation 280
billion let me say it again 280
billion dollars a year you say how could
that be joe
hospital bills physical therapy
trauma counseling legal fees prison
costs
and the loss of productivity
not to mention a psychological damage
done to the children
who live in these cities watching this
happen knowing someone had happened to
this gun violence in our neighborhood is
having profound impact
on our children even if they're never
involved
in pulling the trigger or being the
victim of the other side of
for a fraction of the cost of gun
violence
we can save lives create safe and
healthy communities
and build economies that work for all of
us
and save billions of american dollars
in the meantime much of it as
senator cecilia knows is
taxpayer money
finally the bureau of alcopol alcohol
tobacco and firearms
the key agency enforcing gun laws hasn't
had a permanent director
since 2015. today
i'm proud to nominate david chipman
to serve as the director of the aft
david knows
aft well he served there for 25 years
and vice president harris and i believe
he's the right person
at this moment for this important agency
and i've said before my job the job of
any president is to protect
the american people
whether congress acts or not i'm going
to use all the resources in my disposal
as president to keep the american people
safe from gun violence
but there's much more that congress can
do
to help that effort and they can do it
right now
they've offered plenty of thoughts and
prayers members of congress
but they passed not a single new federal
law to reduce gun violence
enough prayers time for some action
i believe the senate should immediately
pass three house pass bills
to close loopholes that allow gun
purchases
purchasers to bypass the background
checks
the vast majority of the american people
including gun owners believe there
should be background checks
before you purchase a gun as was noted
earlier
hundreds of thousands of people have
been denied guns
because of the background checks what
more would have happened
these bills one require background
checks for anyone purchasing a gun
at a gun show or an online sale most
people don't know
you walk into a store and you buy a gun
you have a background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
second thing is to close the charles
three noises with charleston loophole
like people here i spent time down at
that church in charleston
what happened is someone was allowed
to get the gun used to kill those
innocent people of the church service
if the fbi hasn't
didn't complete the background check
within three days
there's a process wasn't done in three
days according to charleston loophole
you get to buy the gun
they bought the gun and killed a hell of
a lot of innocent people
who invited him to pray with them
and three reauthorize the violence
campsune act
which the so-called clothes
the boyfriend and stalking loopholes to
keep guns out of the hands of people
found by a
court to be an abuser
and continuing threat i held over a
thousand hours of hearings
to pass the violence against women act
and one thing came through
if in fact a stay away order
an order prevented
the abuser from coming in a certain
distance
of the person he has abused or she has
abused
and now the idea that they can
own a weapon when they have a court
order
saying they are an abuser
these are some of the best tools we have
right now to prevent gun violence and
save lives
but all these bills they had supported
both democrats
and republicans in the house and
universal background checks are
supported by the vast majority of
american people
and i might add the vast majority of
responsible gun owners
so let me be clear this is not a
partisan issue
among the american people this is a view
by the american people as an american
issue
and i'm willing to work with anyone to
get these done
and it's long past time that we act
now i know this has been a hobby horse
of mine for a long time
got it done once we should also ban
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines in this country
so that 10 years we had it done
the number of mass shootings actually
went down
even law enforcement officials have told
me and told other
champions of this legislation they
sometimes feel outgunned
by assault weapons with large capacity
magazines
there's no reason someone needs a weapon
of war with 100
rounds 100 bullets that can be fired
from that weapon nobody needs that
nobody needs that
we got that done when i was a united
states senator it wasn't easy
going up against the gun lobby but it
saved lives
and we should also eliminate gun
manufacturers from the immunity they
received from the congress
you realize again the people here
because they're so knowledgeable
on there and the rose garden
but what piece of people don't realize
the only industry in america a billion
dollar industry
that can't be sued as exempt from being
sued
for gun manufacturers imagine how
different it would be
had that same exemption been available
to tobacco companies
who knew who knew and lied about the
danger
they were causing the cancer caused and
the like
imagine where we'd be but this is the
only outfit
that is exempt from being sued
if i get one thing on my list the lord
came down and said joe you get one of
these
give me that one because i tell you what
there would be a come to the lord moment
these folks would have real quickly
but they're not they're not they're
exempt
i know that the conversation about guns
in this country can be a difficult one
but even here there's much more common
ground
than anyone would believe there's much
more common ground
everything that's being proposed today
is totally consistent with the second
amendment
and there's a wide consensus behind the
need to take action
i know that when overwhelming majorities
americans want to see something
change that will affect their lives and
it still doesn't change it can be
demoralizing
to our fellow citizens it can feel like
our entire political process is broken
i know it's painful and frustrating that
we haven't made the progress
that we'd hoped for but it took
five years to get bradyville passed and
it took even more years to work to pass
the assault women's ban
and it saved lives no matter how long it
takes
we're going to get these passed we're
not going to give up
we have an opportunity to fulfill the
first responsibility of government
to keep our people safe and in the
process we can show the world and show
ourselves that democracy works
we can come together and get big things
done
when i look around and see such brave
survivors sitting out here in the rose
garden
public servants who devoted their lives
to dealing with this
advocates who feel strongly and are
pushing every day to make the rational
changes and courageous parents and
family members
i know the progress even in this most
difficult of issues is possible
so folks this is just a start
we've got a lot of work to do but i know
almost every one of you sitting in the
garden here none of you ever given up
we're not going to give up now the idea
that we have so many people dying every
single day
from gun violence in america there's a
blemish on our character as a nation
let me say to all of you god bless you
but most importantly the memory
of all many of you have lost to the
senseless gun violence
and now i'd like to hand it over to the
attorney general
for him to speak and make some comments
i hope i get a chance to see somebody
after this is over
thank you thank you thank you
thank you mr president and madam vice
president
we stand here today not at a moment of
tragedy
but in the midst of an enduring tragedy
so far this year guns have taken the
lives of an estimated 11 000
of our neighbors friends and fellow
americans
as the president explained
gun deaths in our country are occurring
at a staggering pace
on the order of about a hundred
americans killed every day
with hundreds more wounded i
am under no illusions about how hard it
is to solve
the problem of gun violence and i know
that the department of justice alone
cannot solve the problem it is a problem
that we must all work on together
in a collective effort to keep guns out
of the hands of criminals
and save lives but there is work for the
department to do
and we intend to do it today
the department of justice is announcing
several steps that we will take to keep
guns out of the hands of criminals and
reduce the risk of gun violence
first we will ensure that we understand
and measure the problem of criminal gun
trafficking
in a data driven way over 20 years ago
atf undertook a gun trafficking study
it then issued a report that provided
information
necessary to better understand and to
combat
criminal trafficking networks no
such study has been conducted since that
time
accordingly i have directed atf to begin
work on an updated study of criminal gun
trafficking
one that will take into account the fact
that modern guns are not simply cast or
forged anymore
but can also be made of plastic printed
on a 3d
printer or sold in self self-assembly
kits
we will evaluate how some of our best
tools
including the national integrated
ballistics information network
and the national tracing center are
keeping up with the times
and we will analyze our criminal cases
and investigations to determine what
they can show us
about modern gun trafficking patterns
we expect that the lessons from this
study will help agents
prosecutors and policy makers tackle
modern criminal gun trafficking
enterprises
second we will close a regulatory
loophole that has contributed to the
proliferation
of so-called ghost guns federal law
requires that manufacturers mark
all firearms with serial numbers so they
can be traced if they are used in crimes
it also requires licensed firearms
dealers to run
background checks to ensure that
individuals who are barred by law from
purchasing
firearms cannot do so the emergence of
ghost guns
threatens both of these important law
enforcement objectives
currently individuals can buy kits that
contain all
or almost all of the parts they need to
assemble a gun
they can put a working weapon together
in as little as 30 minutes
the kits are aptly called by
build shoot kits
yet because of a gap in the atf
regulations these kits may not be
considered
firearms as a result
they are being made and sold without
serial numbers
and sold without background checks
within 30 days atf will issue a proposed
rule to plug that gap
and to enable law enforcement to trace
crime guns
and to keep guns from being sold to
those who cannot
lawfully possess them third
we will make clear that statutory
restrictions on short short-barreled
rifles apply
when certain stabilizing braces are
added to high-powered pistols
federal law requires the taxation and
registration of
all short-barreled rifles it does so
because
these weapons are powerful yet easily
concealable
currently however some manufacturers
market and some individuals purchase
certain kinds of stabilizing braces that
when attached to a pistol
effectively converted into a
short-barreled rifle
a weapon that is in the words of the
statute quote
intended to be fired from the shoulder
such braces make high-powered pistols
more stable and accurate
while still concealable within 60 days
atf will issue a proposed rule that will
make clear
that when a device marketed as a
stabilizing device
effectively turns a pistol into a
short-barreled rifle
it is subject to the requirements of the
statute
fourth we will publish model red
flag legislation for states
red flag laws as the president has
explained
allow family members or law enforcement
to petition for court orders
that temporarily bar people in crisis
from accessing
firearms if they present a danger to
themselves
or to others 19 states
and the district of columbia have
already made this important step
within 60 days the justice department
will publish
model legislation that will make it
easier for states that want to craft
laws permitting such emergency risk
orders
to do so fifth
we will empower our communities to
combat
and prevent gun violence
we all recognize that although law
enforcement plays an important role
gun violence is not a problem that law
enforcement alone can solve
[Applause]
communities are an essential partner an
asset and a source of resources
and ideas those who are closest to the
problem
are a critical part of solving the
problem
to that end the justice department will
make available over 1
billion dollars in funding through over
a dozen grant programs
that can be used to support
evidence-based intervention strategies
for reducing gun violence
such strategies include but are not
limited to street outreach
violence interrupters and hospital-based
violence intervention
services
i have directed all of our grant-making
components
to come to make community violence
intervention
and pre-end prevention a priority
finally none of these measures or any of
the other critical law enforcement work
the department does with respect to
illegal guns
can be effectively carried out without
strong leadership
that is why the president has nominated
david shipman to be the next
atf director
[Applause]
mr chipman has come up through the ranks
spending 25 years in the trenches
fighting illegal gun trafficking
and criminal enterprises his extensive
experience as an atf agent
will prove invaluable and i look forward
to working with him
looking out at many of you is not
only a reminder of the tragic toll
that gun violence takes on our
communities
but also of the resilience and
determination
that it will take to make our
communities safer
the department of justice shares your
commitment
and that of the president and of the
vice president
to stopping the plague of gun violence
and saving the lives of those we love
thank you
i wasn't supposed to do that i'd like to
see all of you thank you thank you thank
you let's get to work